we're doing it when is it can you get
the ad this is a real ad june oh
let's do that let's go right into an ad
perfect yeah right here here you go
what if i told you that bitcoin is the
future of money now what if i told you
it's going to be an actual in person in
the flesh event this year
focus exclusively on bitcoin and it's
going to be the biggest event in bitcoin
history now what if i continue to tell
you that event will happen
in miami florida on june 4th and 5th and
that i tim dillon was going to be there
too would you believe me it's true
the bitcoin 2021 conference is happening
folks it'll be sunny hot miami florida
june
fourth or fifth headlining the
conference will be jack dorsey
founder of twitter chamath ike pala
he retweets us we like him tony hawk who
is a bitcoiner michael saylor the duda
keeps
taking out a billion dollar loans
against his company to buy bitcoin
and nick sabo he's a fun guy on twitter
tim dylan will also be considered a
headliner if he does a good job with the
ad read
oh there will be a whale day ahead of
the conference if you're
rich like me you need to buy a whale
pass and get there a day earlier on june
3rd
they'll be bitcoin powered we don't even
know what we're doing for this no one's
told us
no no one will let us know no one is
told do you think they're just gonna
execute us in front of all these people
no we've emailed nine times to figure
out what's expected of us
we know we're doing a live podcast we're
doing a live podcast and you're
moderating something
i'm moderating something there'll be
bitcoin-powered arcade games a massive
art gallery with all the most famous
bitcoin artists tony hawk is skating a
half pipe
and much more
an answer party than i'll be opening up
for i i don't even know what's happening
here
this event will be the event of the year
it's going to sell out get your tickets
down go to b
slash tc what no b dot tc
conference i'll put it on the screen
right here and it'll be in the
description yeah go to
b dot tc slash conference promo code tim
dillon
10 off your ticket price am i selling
tickets to this
yeah yeah but am i getting anything from
that
well you're getting paid to do the
bitcoin conference yeah but i mean
that's not what that's not what i'm
gonna
get people to come to this and then go
if you wanna see if you wanna see me do
a live pod we have no idea what's
going on or what we're doing i mean
that's not the greatest sales pitch
but i genuinely don't know we don't know
but it's going to be fun
because it's always fun yeah yeah but do
you know what we're doing
not a clue right neither i don't know if
your agent doesn't know i don't know
what's going on but
we will be in miami and we're going to
do a live podcast
and then i'm moderating an event and it
looks like you might be doing stand-up
at an after-party or something
i don't know no one has said anything
about it
come learn about bitcoin and celebrate
life and freedom at the bitcoin
2021 conference b
dot tc forward slash conference and use
the code tim dillon
10 off jack dorsey is going to be
headlining on twitter is he a bitcoiner
yeah yeah they all are they all are
it should be interesting
i mean i'm wondering
i'm wondering how this is gonna go
you know
like are we gonna be podcasting in like
a half pipe that tony hawk is like
skating in
i don't know
i don't know how this is gonna go
you may want to come and see it to just
see it because i genuinely
do not have an idea it'll be funny
certainly but i don't know
what's gonna happen this will be way
more fun than like a comedy festival or
something 100 percent
yeah i am hoping yeah i believe so
it's a real cultural moment a live tim
dillon show from the biggest bitcoin
conference
i mean it's going to be wild they're
going to talk about everything right all
the coins
dogecoin uh i'm where i want to wear
like a dogecoin
shirt well this one might specifically
just be for bitcoin it looks like oh
okay
but what if i have the dogecoin dog on a
shirt have a little fun
that could be a big hit yeah i mean we
gotta figure something out here
we gotta we gotta do something something
if we put him on the shirt
people can see we're putting the work in
here you know
what else can we do because that was my
idea
do you have any ideas you brought to the
table
well my idea is i i would like us to do
the live podcast with gary vee
i think that would be amazing invitation
to gary vee if you allow me to
i would love it i would really like i
don't know if he's gonna do it
if you know gary let him know that we'd
like him as a guest i will pay garyvee
money to be on the show
at the bitcoin conference it will be a
lot of fun
it will be a lot like he could coach me
as to how to like start a business
[Music]
what i'd like to do is get gary vee and
bring my friend ryan who's a recovering
heroine addict
to the conference and i'd like to have
gary instruct ryan on how to start a
business
that would be that would be my goal
if i could get gary vee to instruct my
recovering heroin addict friend
on how to build a brand
that would be my goal but
it is a weird like we don't it's gonna
be interesting but we don't know
we don't know what's gonna happen are
people gonna sit and listen
i i think it's like a ted talk thing but
with bitcoin like people are gonna sit
around talking i mean but to our podcast
yes yes i believe so we should get a
guest
who are we going to get for well my idea
was gary v
um i would noted i guess noted another
guess could be
little zen well zan
y'all like bitcoin
but i'm dead serious shouldn't we have a
guess
who
you're the producer of this show you
went today and made a mess about
pickleball
you lied on the show and said i did you
mean you did nearly the same
we did not you blew a lot of high
profile things i blew a few of them
but you blew some seriously and i had an
amazing serve
people noticed that i had a skill set
yeah i was a little bit chaotic in my
skill set
you were really all over the court and
you kept cheating
you kept going into the kitchen which is
the thing you shouldn't go into that i
was wearing clarks though
if i was wearing tennis shoes i could
have stopped on time yeah i mean
everyone's got a story
but you know that area right by the net
you kept going into and cheating
what about roseanne like i'm dead
serious oh amazing can we fly roseanne
to the bitcoin conference from hawaii
sure
i don't know what we're gonna we gotta
do something here
i'm dead sir paying us money we gotta
figure out something
what if we get chamath to explain
bitcoin to roseanne
something like this has got to happen
i'm telling you
we need to get
somebody who needs to explain bitcoin to
someone else who's completely
off the planet that's
the fusion i want to make i want to make
this happen
i want to take a bitcoin expert
maybe i'll just get one of my friends
who's like from long island who's just
completely shot i don't know
but that's what needs to happen here
whitney webb is coming up she's going
to be here to discuss getting thrown off
of
patreon why that happened
she's also going to talk about vaccine
passports why she's skeptical
that the maxwell new charges mean much
we told her we'd have her back if the
maxwell thing goes to trial which we
don't know if it will or not
it's supposed to in july yeah we'll also
be
the we got an episode with stan hope on
the patreon right now the higher tier
because we we kind of [ __ ] them over
we didn't mean to
uh we were going to do a big long
episode with doug and put it out this
week but it just didn't work it just
kind of went off the rails at the end it
was like this was what we could do here
we can't
you know um but we'll be back there
lovely people love them both doug and
bingo
um we'll be back there uh so we got that
rocket and rolling we got live dates a
lot of them are sold out the
majority of them are sold out um and we
got more being announced all the time
the world's opening up and
uh we're out there having a lot of fun
or
just doing what we have to do as a job
you choose
your choice some of it is fun but
you know i hope this is fun
what about aj i
was kind of thinking that or like maybe
even you know they're shutting alex
jones down they're not letting that
happen
because what about if alex jones like
charged jack dorsey
on stage he's like you [ __ ]
and jack twice like who the [ __ ]
brought alex jones and it's like oh the
comedian that we hired it would be
really cool if we like snuck
alex in he stayed at our hotel and we
got him like to enter the back door
he just like like the kool-aid man just
popped into the conference
yeah well now that we've yeah no one
will figure that out now
you just put that plan out there dum-dum
well no i mean it's it's clearly it's
clearly
a situation where i we need to bring in
a guess who else would you said alex and
then you were thinking of somebody else
oh um um maybe someone's
like i was thinking like not just like
maxwell of course because she's not on
bail but i'm trying to think of someone
we also can't talk to a human trafficker
for goofs
we can't bring on a human trafficker for
a bit people would get angry at that and
rightly so
like yucking it up with just lane
maxwell who's tortured children
there's got to be some line what about
rogan should i email rogan
text him email him a formal offer tell
him we'll pay him 1500
to appear
hear me out okay hear me out yeah yeah
hear me out
are you ready yeah yeah are you ready
do you know what i'm about to say no how
well do you know me
very well almost as well as anybody
probably better than anyone that's
exactly right yeah
who am i gonna say [ __ ]
what about
eric weinstein
in a world why not
that would be the absolute perfect gig
perfect guest
why not how about eric
brat
eric brett heather jordan peterson
michaela peterson sam harris
barry weiss
roxanne gay what about roxane gay
i don't know i don't know anymore
what if we just had the wine scenes on
we talked about trans people for three
hours people like what does this have to
do with bitcoin
talk about the coin we're getting
hackled we're like puberty blockers
they're like
talk about the [ __ ] coin we're here
to make money
we should talk about what a great troll
to talk about something completely
unrelated
there's something that's nothing to do
with it we're just talking about the
kennedy assassination for an hour
to go yeah that was not the room for
that they really went off the
rails we just
what if we bring sharon osborne in and
get her drunk and have her just
[ __ ] go crazy shouting asian slurs
amazing
you know this [ __ ] wontons
[ __ ] people
piers morgan mm-hmm john mcafee
he's not gonna step on salta's u.s soil
right
yeah he's like still on the run steve
bannon could be interesting too
steve bannon at a bit now that'll be a
major story if he would do it the
conference people would probably get mad
they don't want to politicize it maybe
i'm wrong maybe they're friends with him
i have no idea
they probably are behind closed doors
but in front of those doors
they're going to act like you have no
idea who he is
all these billionaires stopped
pretending they didn't know who trump
was when he got elected it's like wait
what
um matt gates what about matt gates
what about donald trump jr
dt june
i think he'd do it trying to think who
we could get that would actually be good
for like for the show
what if we had like we it's got to be
someone in that world
well yeah i mean if john mcafee can step
on u.s soil he would be legendary if we
give him some
white russians and just let him go right
he's amazing
right well anyway as you can tell we've
we've planned
out a real big grade of event and we've
dotted all the i's and crossed all the t
so go to b dot tc slash conference
that's all fake we know exactly we're
doing it's going to be amazing
b dot tc forward slash conference you
used to go tim dillon for 10
off